The medium is roughly divided into two types, the optical gun and the live ammunition.The
optical medium is compact, lightweight, and has a long range and high accuracy.
During live bullets,
yeah, the bullets have a lot of mass, and the input is strong, so they can't be blocked by a defensive field.
So let's teach you the basic handling inside
redline It happens the moment you put your finger on the trigger of a gun like redline
If you see a bullet line flying on this line, immediately counterattack or avoid it nger
Tighten your armpits  Hold the gun and put your finger on the bank
This is the bullet circle ballistic prediction If the bug you chose pulls the trigger, the ball will
hit the circle randomly
Try to hit it,
tan You're the worst bug among grass insects  I
can assure you that if you go out into the world, you will die of a certain disease.You must want to see it.The
size of the circle changes according to the pulsation.Keep your
mind calm and
shoot.
You seem to have taken care of that [ __ ] bug
with the Submachine Gundam.